sogar ein ladekabel habe ich dazu
bekommen und jetzt nehmt euch in acht
[Musik]
etwas knapper netz bekommen beim ein
video für das heutige video
es ist auf jeden fall was kraft passiert
ich weiß gar nicht so genau wie ich
anfangen soll
ich kann nur erst mal sagen das müsst
ihr nicht machen das will keiner von
euch machen das will ich ganz okay und
fangen wir ganz am anfang an
ich habe glaube ich vormonat oder so ein
video gemacht da sind wir gerade neu
eingezogen
da habe ich dann so als spaß im video
gesagt leute wir brauchen noch im
zweiten ps4 controller weil wir halt nur
ein haben und wir wollten gegen an der
fifa spielen oder so also ich gegen mein
mitbewohner und schaffte es so gesagt ja
kommen wenn einer an playstation
controller zu viel angst schickt ihn
einfach an die adresse von mein netzwerk
also hier in köln aber an sich habe ich
das nicht wirklich ernst meinen klar wir
hätten uns sehr gefreut ist dass
irgendwer gemacht aber das war an sich
nur spaß so nicht auch etwas länger
überlegt ob ich hier das video mache
weil an sich ist es auch nicht so
notwendig aber ich wollte euch einfach
mal zeigen was passiert ist und was sich
im liebes mädchen gedacht hat also an
sich muss ich sagen vielen dank so aber
und verfolge ich habe die letzten im
paket bekommt das wurde mir ausgehändigt
also jetzt nicht genau an meine adresse
hier sondern halt an mein netzwerk und
von da aus habe ich dort hoben sich auf
an alex w das komisch ist auch es ist
eine briefmarke drauf aber es ist kein
stempel drauf deswegen ist geh mal davon
aus dass wurde einfach da ein geworfen
was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären
keine ahnung ich weiß auch nicht seit
wann das schon ist ja das glaube ich
folgt ihr tag oder zu bekommen also
erstmal für das paket ich habe jetzt ein
gutes geht wieder zugemacht weil ich
will das jetzt leichter mit euch
zusammen auspacken aber an sich weil sie
als 100 drin ist weil ich jetzt von
einer durch leser hat mit hat mich
natürlich sofort interessiert ich wollte
wissen was da drinnen hat aufgewacht
kein variante wasserlos am titel gelesen
in dem paket ist jetzt kein ei phone 7
auch kein iphone wächst loslassen aber
halten iphone einfach ein iphone was sie
noch mal ein bisschen mehr aus
so riecht irgendwie verfolgt der leute
fast aus wir haben ja erst mal sogar ein
ladekabel habe ich dazu bekommen und
jetzt nehmt euch in acht eine
zuschauerin hat mir einfach ihr eigenes
iphone 5 geschickt das hier ist ein
iphone 5 1 und es einfach ein ganz
normales uns aber voll funktionsfähig
glaube ich habe es irgendwie schon mal
an und das ist wirklich ein original
iphone 5 und mein klar das ist jetzt
nicht das neueste aber es ist ein iphone
und iphone verlieh nicht so leicht an
wert also dafür hättest du auf jeden
fall noch eine gewisse sogar an geld
bekommen
2 es ist ja auch nicht lukas der kraft
das sieht an sich noch ganz okay aus
wieso schickt mehr iphone ich möchte
kein iphone von dir du kannst du nicht
einfach ein iphone geben ich mein okay
ich drücke mich erst an der tu karte
eingesehen habe ich auch schon mal
gelesen mal im schnelldurchlauf an alex
die lieber alex erst einmal wollte ich
dir sagen dass du sehr coole youtube
videos macht bleibt bitte so wie du bist
denn so lieben wir dich erstmal dazu
danke freut mich sehr so etwas zeigt
immer sehr gerne so ansonsten ich habe
letztens ein video gesehen wo du gesagt
was das ihr noch einen playstation
controller braucht weiter habe ich
keinen griechischen controller zu hause
aber ich wollte dir immer schon
unbedingt mal etwas schenken wir möchten
wir denn unbedingt verschenkt mich freut
wenn du meine videos und mich immer
unterstützt
du kannst gerne pulli von mir kaufen
damit unterstützt er sich natürlich doch
mit ihr mehr
aber du solltest du kein iphone schicken
niemand muss mir ein iphone senken ich
habe auch selber ein iphone ich brauche
nicht noch einen besseren habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich jemand altes handy
schenkel
ich habe letztens zum geburtstag sowieso
ein neues bekommen und deshalb weiß ich
nicht was ich mit meinem alten machen
soll
bitte denken ich bin ein zwölfjähriges
fendel ich wollte dir einfach nur eine
freude machen und die etwas für deinen
tollen videos zurückgeben liebe grüße
für ihn das was da steht sein nachname
das sieht kein abseits das steht gar
nichts das heißt ich habe jetzt ein
iphone sagen wir zwei berlin ist 15
mit 15 einfach ein iphone superschicken
stoppen oder zwei wochen ladekabel ich
meine das ist sogar glaube ich ein
originales ladekabel das kostet auch
noch mal 30 euro
ganz neu ist zudem was soll ich mit ihr
machen also ich bin eigentlich fest
davon überzeugt
du mich so sehr mag sofort was
eigentlich dieses video auch gerade wenn
ein titel steht zuschauerin oder so
schenk mir ein iphone einfach
deutschland sind die durch schreiben des
jahres elin mit schreiten wir irgendwo
scheiß egal wo sag mir bitte warum er
das gemacht ist und ich würde dir das
iphone gerne zurück schicken damit du es
verkaufen kann ich weiß wenn ich kann
deine eltern nichts dagegen gesagt hast
du einfach irgendwem wild trend es
eigentlich einfach dein iphone fans ohne
spaß würde ich das jetzt bei ebay
einstellen ich will dafür locker noch
100 euro bekommen oder auch 150 gut
werde ich natürlich nicht machen aber
wollte die nummer sagen guck mal 115 du
kannst du einfach zwei paar neue schuhe
kaufen oder s-bahn oder sieben von
meinen police kaufen ja also das wollte
ich euch noch mal gesagt haben bitte
schenkt mir nie so teure sachen so was
möchte ich gar nichts da fühle ich mich
automatisch nicht mit ansonsten
natürlich dank ist für ihn das dass du
mich anzeigen so toll finde ist dass du
das gemacht hat
das wäre nicht nötig gewesen und ich
möchte sehr sehr sehr sehr gerne das
handy wieder zurückschicken damit du es
verkaufen kann oder es dem anlass senken
kann
der ist vielleicht nötiger als ich
wehrleute so viel wollte das jetzt erst
mal sagen ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben eure meinung wie
steht ihr dazu ist das total
nachvollziehbar alex reagiert von über
das iphone bereit ist doch cool soder
sagt hinein alex du hast recht das
möchte man zurückschicken er wer
kritische frage ansonsten wen wir uns am
sonntag wieder floss 06 ad und instagram
diesen und zahlreichen und kauft ihr
police kaufen polizei die bewerbung